[Applaudissements]
il ya plein de nouvelles rumeurs sur le
futur iphone qui va sortir l'iphone 8
on va aller en parler seulement ici il
fait pas très beau dehors il ya un temps
exceptionnel un grand soleil sur les
farines ban avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
on va parler de l'iphone 8 comme se le
dise il ya plein de nouveautés dont on
va pouvoir parler il ya des plans qu'ils
existent jeter chez p sur le net
fake ou pas je sais pas toujours est il
que ça parle du futur iphone 8 s'est
déjà fait une vidéo il ya pas longtemps
pour parler de l'après midi pour parler
des différentes rumeurs d'ailleurs je
t'invite à cliquer pour aller voir et
tout savoir qu' il ya déjà pas mal de
choses qui étaient déjà dit et qui sont
sortis en réalité dans le nouveau
samsung galaxy s suit l'iphone 8 fait
beaucoup parler de lui parce qu'il est
normalement attendu ils correspondent à
sortie des dix ans du premier iphone en
2007 où steve jobs avait fait une qui
n'ose vraiment dingue il avait vraiment
introduit un tout nouveau produit par
rapport à la première vidéo je t'avais
fait on connaît plus de choses on a plus
d'infos sur ce nouvel iphone en réalité
il y aura pas un iphone mais trois
iphone le premier iphone ça sera
l'iphone 8 le classique
ensuite tu auras l'iphone 8 + plus grand
modèle plus grand écran alors les
feuilles 8 aura un écran de 4,7 pouces
et l'iphone vive plus normalement en
écrans de 5,5 pouces et il y aura
ensuite le troisième iphone qui sera
l'iphone pour les 10 ans de l'iphone
justement l'iphone anniversaire on
connaît pas le nom il n'y a rien
d'officiel tout de suite soit l'iphone
10 avec une grande croix pour
effectivement annoncé les 10 ans soit
l'iphone édition édition ça reste la
gamme très premium de chez apple qu'on
avait pu retrouver notamment au niveau
des watch lounge édition qui était quand
même beaucoup plus cher que les autres
ou alors l'iphone anniversaire toujours
est il qu'on sait pas on verra bien quel
sera le nom de ce futur iphone on pense
qu'il y aura deux modèles qui sortiront
en septembre et un autre sortira
peut-être un petit peu plus tard le
modèle spécial qui serait annoncée et
qui sortira probablement un tout petit
peu plus tard
côté technique c'est l'iphone qui
devrait être un petit peu plus boosté
avec 3 giga de mémoire contre 2 gigas
son iphone cet actuel le modèle
anniversaire devrait avoir un écran qui
sera encore plus grand un écran de 5,8
pouces oled bord à bord par contre pas
d'incurver cette fois ci comme on peut
retrouver sur les samsung
ça serait vraiment un écran plat un
écran plat excuse moi mais en bord à
bord qui les cinq des huit pouces à
l'intérieur doit y avoir une nouvelle
puce à 11 une carte mère stack plus
compact qu'un iphone qui devrait
ressembler à l'iphone 4
avec des bordures métallique un écran en
verre derrière et sur le devant à
l'heure sur le devant sera pas la même
chose
ça sera un écran différents dire
beaucoup plus grand tu auras vraiment un
écran bord à bord mais encadrent un
petit peu ce stade p d'objets un petit
peu précieux côté métallique
probablement beaucoup plus légers parce
que l'iphone 4 faisait quand même son
poids il faut le savoir
normalement je te l'avais dit ça le
bouton home disparaît tout en bas il
devrait y avoir une espèce de doc in
touch barque comme on retrouve sur les
sur les nouveaux macbook pro tu devrais
te retrouves avec ces espèces de touch
bar virtuel qui pourra probablement être
décliné en fonction des applications et
on pourra faire plein de choses
différentes en fonction de l'application
dans laquelle tu seras 7 permettra
d'avoir un bouton de déverrouillage
hommes avec probablement une
reconnaissance
d'empreintes digitales je dis
probablement parce qu'on n'est pas sûr
on pense normalement qui en aura une
derrière mais ça je t'expliquerai tout à
l'heure donc ce fameux dock en bas avec
7 touch barre pour pouvoir aller plus
loin dans les applications ça sera
vraiment sympa parce qu'on aura vraiment
quelque chose de dédier un dock dédié et
en façade
tu vas te retrouver avec un appareil
photo et le haut parleur qui seront
planqué sous la dalle alors tu me dira
comment est ce que le son à faire pour
passer si le haut parleur et sous la
dalle alors assure-toi la dalle sera
micro perforé pour laisser passer le
sombre donc ça devrait plutôt bien se
passer
mais voilà une dalle qui va complètement
recouvrir l'écran d'ailleurs un écran
complet ce qui fait qu on aura beaucoup
plus on aura un écran qui sera beaucoup
plus grand et comme on retrouve
d'ailleurs sur le samsung galaxy s uite
sur les modèles qui sont en train de se
développer actuellement coté recharge ça
sera effectivement une batterie un peu
plus grande un peu plus boosté qui
durera plus longtemps avec une recherche
sans fil en induction donc normalement
ça devrait effectivement permettre
d'avoir une recharge probablement plus
rapides mais surtout une batterie qui
durera plus longtemps alors la batterie
effectivement elle est toujours lié à
l'utilisation et à je dirais à la
consommation qu'on va en faire mais en
tout cas pour une utilisation classique
ou là ou un iphone dure un jour
normalement en faire toute la lumière
un jour quoique en ce moment il ya un
petit peu moins ça devrait durer un
petit peu plus longtemps
normalement tu vas te retrouver avec le
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui sera
pas devant comme sur les iphone 6 aces
ou sur les sept que tu as mais derrière
en dessous du bouton justement gcp ces
infos sur le site macrumors.com que je
t'invite à aller voir ailleurs j'aime
interviendra description parce qu'ils
ont toutes les rumeurs sur les derniers
iphone surtout produits apple
et c'est vraiment super bien fichu ça
c'est le document qui a été partagée
qu'ils ont eut récupéré je ne lis pas le
chinois je ne sais pas où mais tu vois
très très bien que là tu vas avoir ici
une zone un bouton qui va servir aux
réalités en déverrouillage donc ça sera
un capteur d'empreintes digitales pu le
voir autrement sur cet autre document là
sans lag documents de la coque arrière
où tu vois bien cette partie là la
centrale où tu pourras effectivement
devenu ton téléphone directement prendra
le téléphone comme ça et tu auras le
déverrouillage pour logo tu leur feras
tu auras le déverrouillage juste en
dessous ça sera plus pratique que sur
les samsung galaxy où tu te retrouves
vers l'appareil photo tu peut rapidement
mettre le doigt sur l'appareil photo ça
peut être gens là ça sera centrale et
amanda lear tenue demain ça sera quand
même vachement mieux
pas mal non alors puisqu'on prend de la
façade arrière tu auras un appareil
photo qui sera normalement sur qui sera
à la verticale tu peux voir ici un
appareil photo à la verticale double
capteur dispatch connaît un appareil
photo double optique qui placé
verticalement permettront de réalité de
réaliser de meilleures photos et de
meilleures vidéos ça tu le vois
effectivement sur l'iphone c'est déjà ça
de fait ne cède plus excuse moi tu es
une profondeur de champ
donc ils vont effectivement plus loin au
niveau de la qualité photo tous vraiment
des appareils qui sont qui sont top
la reconnaissance faciale sur l'appareil
photo face avec de nouvelles
technologies qui permettront de
déverrouiller avec une reconnaissance à
l'iris qui permettront effectivement a
priori de capter les mouvements donc est
ce qu'il y aura une façon de
déverrouiller ou des mouvements qui
seront captés qui nous permettront
d'aller plus loin dans certaines
applications
ça sera vraiment des choses à voir
toujours est il que cet appareil photo à
l'avant sera vraiment d'une meilleure
qualité un téléphone qui va être
certifié ip 68 ce qui fait qu'il pourra
rester trente minutes sous un mètre
cinquante d'eau alors c'est pas de but
on va pas s'amuser à ajouter sous l'eau
mais si tu ne mouille
si tu prends la pluie si tu vas je ne
sais où d'anglo doussain toujours tu
aura en tout cas une certification et tu
auras un produit qui sera garanti donc
tu aura pas de problème alors il faut se
méfier parce que certification ip ip ip
68 elle ne protège pas tout
en termes de garantie il faut vraiment
faire attention à tout ce qui va être
rock loreo piscine au salé l'amer
normalement ça peut te faire sauter la
garantie à vérifier à regarder mais j'ai
déjà lu des choses là-dessus où il faut
faire vraiment très très attention à
être extrêmement vigilant que ces choses
là normalement c'est pas un appareil qui
devrait avoir pour l'instant de l'usbc
l'usb ça devrait arriver un petit peu
plus tard probablement en 2018 chapple
pour l'instant de regarder le port
lightning comme on a ici ce qui te
permettra peut-être d'avoir de la
recherche par lightning mais normalement
non c'est vraiment que l'induction
est-ce qu'ils vont quand même garder la
recharge en câbles en deuxième option ça
pour l'instant c'est pas trop toujours
est il que tu pourras normalement
brancher des écouteurs dessus pour ceux
qui n'ont pas les airs pod et qui
veulent pas investir une centaine
d'euros dans l'air pod
tu pourras normalement de câbles et
directement dans le port lightnin donc
ça rassurez vous il sera conservé côté
capacité on va garder un iphone d'entrée
de gamme à 64 giga store notera quand
même de mettre pas mal de choses dedans
et tu pourra monter jusqu'à 256 giguère
256 giga normalement tu peux voir venir
tu peux mettre de la musique des vidéos
d'autant plus que tu veux vraiment
qu'ils augmentent la qualité en termes
de photos et en terme de vidéo donc plus
de stockage plus de besoins de stockage
donc c'est quand même bien d'avoir des
cas l'idée d'avoir des produits accrue
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ce sur ce nouveau
téléphone de chez apple sur les
nouvelles rumeurs là tu vois
effectivement à quoi devrait ressembler
avec 7,7 dan qui va de bord à bord pas
d'actu revêt pour le moment en tout cas
sur ce produit là un tout petit con tour
un objet métallique un déverrouillage
par l'arrière un meilleur appareil photo
donc fait voilà autre avoir un super
produit
moi ce que j'attends vraiment ils
attendent que j'ai par rapport à ce
produit surtout au niveau de
l'accessoire tout ce qu'on attend c'est
super ça arrive c'est plutôt dans les
standards actuels
on voit qu'effectivement il ya une
concurrence accrue et qu'il ya une
montée en gamme au niveau des
constructeurs tout va que le samsung
galaxy s suit maintenant la question et
qu'en est-il de la réalité virtuelle
pour l'instant j'ai rien vu de vraiment
intéressant dessus mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui pour moi est super
important ce que j'attends réellement
d'un peu sur ce produit s'est
effectivement d'avoir un produit plus
puissant plus robuste avec des grandes
capacités de stockage où on puisse
mettre beaucoup de choses dedans avec
des grands écrans pour pouvoir
effectivement voir des vidéos pour
pouvoir profiter faire des belles photos
des belles vidéos mais surtout on va
vraiment ce qui se développe qui pour
l'instant est encore un marché de niche
mais qui est vraiment en train de se
développer c'est la réalité virtuelle et
la réalité augmentée
facebook a fait sa conférence sont
réfutés pas longtemps où ils ont
effectivement présenté ce qui sera de la
réalité augmentée directement dans leur
application et même de la réalité
virtuelle pour tout ce qui va être je
dirais vide
pas forcément de la conférence mais ne
serait ce que le futur de messenger
tu m as ton casque tu sera projeté dans
une réalité que tu connais ou pas tu
mettras le fond tu voudras et ensuite tu
pourra dialoguer avec des amis avec leur
avatar c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est en train de se développer et sur
lequel il faut que tout le monde aille
donc si apple ne fait pas un casque de
réalité virtuelle ou qui a pas un
produit effectivement qui va pouvoir ce
câble est directement sur la réalité
virtuelle
je suis très inquiet pour eux ce que
j'attends vraiment d'eux c'est d'avoir
un iphone 8 d'extrême qualité et surtout
de pouvoir avoir de la réalité virtuelle
d'autant plus que tu vas vraiment que
lesquels et les caméras à 360 degrés
sont en train de se démocratiser les
gérait en réalité virtuelle bon couple
ou vont beaucoup plus loin
les casques se développe énormément le
gamme galaxy et suite à son casque de
réalité virtuelle oculus se développe
énormément faut absolument qu apple nous
présente un produit avec un casque de
réalité virtuelle
s'ils veulent pas louper le coche s'y
attendre 2018 pour se caler sur la
réalité virtuelle
j'ai vraiment peur qu'ils prennent leur
retard et moi en tout cas j'ai vraiment
envie d'avoir un casque de qualité voire
de la réalité virtuelle de qualité pas
forcément sur deux jeux vidéo mais sur
pas d'application on sait que ça va
développer
moi même j'ai envie de faire de plus en
plus de gens envie de faire des vidéos
auraient en 360° sita parce que de
casques de réalité virtuelle que
seulement en train de te déplaces est
ton téléphone c'est extrêmement
frustrant
donc il faut un casque qui aille avec
cet iphone j'espère vraiment qui va être
annoncé en tout cas voilà les dernières
rumeurs qu'on peut annoncer aujourd'hui
sur ce produit
dis moi ce que t'en penses intime un
petit commentaire tu me dis si ça
correspond à ses attentes
quels sont tes attentes et puis si c'est
un produit qui le séduit et que tu
penses à acheter
[Musique]
je t'emmènerai comme ça régulièrement
faire des tours dans les petits pois qui
sont relativement sympa tu verras qu'il
y avait vraiment des jolis points à
visiter regarde ça si c'est pas cool ça
c'est cool il est maintenant possible si
tu souhaites m'envoyer une petite photo
de toi mon voyais un dessin m'envoyer
n'importe quoi tu peux le faire il ya
une adresse postale qui existe alors je
te la donne pour m'écrire c'est super
simple tu m'écris à monsieur greu 49 rue
de ponthieu 75008 paris
hélas comme ça je reçois des courriers
des petites photos alors je pense
notamment si tu aimes envoyer une petite
photo de toi un polaroïd une connerie
pour ajouter dans ma déco au studio ça
sera relativement sympa parce que là on
part de loin il ya encore énormément de
boulot donc toutes les contributions
sont les bienvenues alors que ça ne
coûtait pas grand chose un petit arbre
une connerie tu y penses tu veux le
faire ça me fera extrêmement plaisir
d'ailleurs s'il ya des marques qui ont
envie d'envoyer des produits des petits
cadeaux titre connaît des choses comme
ça avoir c'est de bienvenue monsieur
greu 49 rue de ponthieu p o nt h1 eu 75
mille 008 paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moucheron qui s'est suicidé
y'avait pas bien envie de vivre sur la
fougue lomagne parce que pour voir au
resto ce soir et les potes je suis comme
d'habitude était en retard ce soir on va
bouffer de la super viande dans un super
resto je vais te montrer quelques images
tu vas me dire ce que tu en personne
[Musique]
je
là
[Musique]